hello and welcome to this video clink
remastered Jasper last counts on right
yes'm Dutch expert let's see f4 em yeah
unfortunately not a move you can refute
not so bad the six is a funny reply that
I think lead to interesting play let's
see what he does
yeah this is asking to already quite
okay for lucky taking on e5 doesn't look
dangerous I'm threatening you far though
one I've got easy development aha so
each for this Bishop a seven
pratik here what happens yeah this is
this apiece mr. Carlson this b7 hanging
it might not be all that clear that
Quincy six at the end still somewhat
messy but ok I think I think there
should be reasonably easy because now
I'm threatening his rook and 97 which
she does not feel as was reacting to
know he's got Bishop a 3m but I can take
this and to Bishop that's a lot okay and
I can't take this check so let's do that
first and now I could take the bishop as
well okay but 97 he's checking me and
then what c-54 can also can also just
just go to his sex on there yeah 36
after Queen takes e7 he doesn't even
have a check threat or this one I didn't
see this one but ok pawn to c6 then
Knight c3 or what no left of screen g2 a
check what am I actually up I'm gonna
look up and the piece up right look and
the pieces 3mon career it's a lot that's
what I'm trying to say yes but I have to
check as well I don't have to take the
rook it shouldn't be bad and then I'm
taking a 3
[Music]
now it's looking to pieces to take
another ruler you what is the thread
95 9 h 6 I mean I have so many pieces my
king is we going to be safe and what now
no check and this rook is hanging
actually so maybe this one
and to Roxanne and two pieces up okay
yes sir this d 6 line is not too bad of
course against f1 d5 is finer or g6 or
whatever this is not too bad so the term
bit more non-standard before is probably
an interesting movie n after which my
intention is to place this which is a
bit strange understand but it's
certainly not too bad because I mean
this is a weird Scandinavian with the
elks remove f4 which is not helping so
maybe this one but then this should be
somewhat okay I mean looks a little bit
like some weird color car or so and
where and for stride early on yeah this
is should be fine and it's just blunder
sense that just blunder stuff Bishop f7
was bitten more interesting this just
didn't work at all yeah yeah okay TR 9
p-6 was also possible with okay it's
just too much I wonder could I actually
take this and then then you have the
draw I have to go to f5 again I mean
just better to take this it keeps
everything completely safe yeah this is
minus 19 yeah I was a bit too much but
it can happen here whenever you move the
earth porner tweenage for check even
happens to GM sometimes and literature
yeah thanks for watching